it is clear that the dialectic of sensor
D is nothing else but the simple history
of its movement or of its experience and
sense certainty itself is nothing else
but just this history that is why the
natural consciousness - is always
reaching this result learning from
experience what is true in it but
equally it is always forgetting and
starting the movement all over again
it is therefore astonishing when in the
face of this experience it is asserted
as universal experience and put forward
to as a philosophical proposition even
as the outcome of skepticism that the
reality or beating of external things
taken as this is or cenis objects as
absolute truth for consciousness to make
such an assertion is not to know what
one is saying to be unaware that one is
saying the opposite of what one wants to
say the truth for consciousness of a
this of sense is supposed to be
universal experience but the very
opposite is universal experience every
consciousness itself supersedes such a
truth and for example here is a treaty
or now is new and proclaims the opposite
here is not a tree but a house and
similarly it immediately against it
precedes the assertion which set aside
the fruits so far as it is also just an
assertion of a sensuous this and what
consciousness will learn from experience
is in all set of certainty in also
certainty it has in truth only what we
have seen that is the this as a
universal the very opposite of what that
assertion affirm to be universal
experience with its appeal to universal
experience we may be permitted to
anticipate how the case stands in the
Pratt
else fear in this respect we can tell
those who assert the truth and certainty
of the reality of sense objects that
they should go back to the most
elementary school of wisdom that is the
ancient eleven Simeon mysteries of Ceres
and Bacchus and that they have still to
learn the secret meaning of the eating
of Brandon and the drinking of wine for
he that is initiated into these
mysteries not only comes to doubt the
being of sensuous things but to despair
of it in part he brings about the
nothingness of such things himself in
his dealings with them and in part he
sees them reduced themselves to
nothingness even the animals are not
shut out from this wisdom but on the
contrary show themselves to be most
profoundly initiated into it for the you
not stand just stand idly in front of
sensuous things as if those possessed
intrinsic being but despairing of the
reality and completely assured of their
nothingness they fall to without
ceremony and eat them up at all nature
like the animal celebrates these open
mysteries which teach the truth about
sensuous things
paragraph 109 is the penultimate part of
sense certainty and it's pretty long
there's a lot going on there but I think
we can divide it into three main things
Hegel is talking about what's going on
with the dialectic of sense certainty
and how that leads to what's going on
for natural consciousness that's one
thing I don't have on the board
what he's talking about in terms of
skepticism and he's not using the term
but but essentially empiricism but we're
going to talk about that as well and
then he's got this really fascinating
passage about the mysteries about these
Greek mysteries and the eating of the
bread and the drinking of the wine and
what's going on with that what is its
deeper significance so he says that the
dialectic of sense certainty turns out
to be the history of its movement or of
experience and so what does that mean
well all these passages that we've
looked at before in which we've been
following along with what happens in
sense certainty that's that dialectic we
have been having the experience and you
might say that well that's just an
intellectual experience I've just been
watching you you know write things on
the board or reading Hegel or listening
to your lecture know if you've actually
been doing this the right way you've
been reflecting on well what is it like
when I experience something when I think
that I have sense experiences about
which I can be completely certain I can
take it as I acknowledge absolute
knowledge of that sort of thing if
you've been following along with that
you've seen that there's a lot more
involved in this that it turns out that
there's all these relations and
mediations and negativity and you know
we've had some achievements along the
way we've realized what a universal is
at least you know for Hegel we've come
to understand the importance of the
relationship between subject and object
we've realized that now we're here or
this
even I are universals that apply to
particulars we've also realized or
foreshadowed the importance of what it
means that there's another I who can
perceive or the fact that I'm an I who
consists of a bunch of eyes over time
a manifold succession of eyes we've
realized that temporality spaciality are
quite complicated so you know we've
packed a lot into these these paragraphs
haven't we that's a history that's a
Gupta a story that's an hour far rung an
experience we should leave this a little
bit different not just in our intellect
but perhaps in our feelings and our
practical importance could be that
you're feeling it's just puzzling to
this point we should leave it a little
bit different than we entered it now
here's where it gets really interesting
so he says this dialectic of sense
certainty that is the history of its
movement or experience is actually send
certainty sense certainty itself is
nothing else but this history what does
that mean well this is where we're gonna
get to the natural consciousness because
the set certainty that he's talking
about there is something that we're
going through over and over and over
again so hingle is not just engaging in
some sort of abstract musing about what
happens when we perceive things and you
know what's involved in that you know
what is perception include he's actually
talking about a process that before we
begin doing philosophy we've already got
a lot of you know you might call it work
time or experience in with but we don't
realize that we do in part because one
of the things we have to do is move
ourselves away from the position of
natural consciousness but the actual
consciousness is where we begin so what
does natural consciousness do natural
consciousness and you know if you're
sort of confused about what he means by
natural conscious
you want to go back to some of the
earlier videos from the preface where he
was actually talking about that
so he says natural consciousness is
always reaching this result learning
from experience what is true in it so
natural consciousness has sense
certainty it's engaging with objects
it's locating that mat here or the air
or now or then and now that's doing that
it starts to realize the truth of sense
certainty which is that things are more
complex and it may do this in a
theoretical way or it may do this in a
purely practical you know commonsensical
way but it comes to free itself to a
certain extent from what we might call
the fascination of the particular being
bedazzled
by the singular experience that it has
and it realizes that if it wants to try
to hold on to those experiences it
actually has to make an effort to do
that this may happen in all sorts of
ways a great example is when we're
dealing with pleasant experiences you
need a piece of chocolate cake you know
chocolate is something that is consumed
temporarily right so here we're charting
things out in terms of nouns that first
bite of cake is probably better than the
last bite of cake it's just the way our
olfactory and gustatory faculties work
you know I'm not sure exactly about the
mechanics of this I don't need to be but
you get the idea that if you try to hold
on to that one single experience you
find yourself more and more
you know seeing it recede off into the
distance slip out of your grasp and
become something that it's not same
thing happens when you try to hold on to
the pleasure that comes with a massage
or slipping into a hot tub or laying in
the Sun you know we can't recapture
contrary to what some people believe
lost time at least not in the sense of
going
back to and maintaining that present
moment we can do all sorts of dodges we
can try to repeat it over and over but
it's never quite the same is it and we
could say the same thing for spaciality
I'll give you it is just an example of
this when I was a kid I grew up in the
countryside and what was at that time a
subdivision but a subdivision that very
very few people had moved into that it
used to be old farmland that was on
rolling hills and had been covered up by
Meadows and quite a few you know wooded
areas and it was just wonderful to grow
up there as a kid because I could range
over miles of territory in very you know
beautiful settings and you know screw
around the way that kids do and we there
were you know a few of us living there
at the time and we did that and then
sooner or later it all got developed and
when I go back there I can't have the
same experience that I wanted to have I
can't go back to the same place why
because that's the way the world works
you know you can't hold things constant
in time you can't even hold a space
constant either now it's not as if you
know it's geographically shifted
position but you know if are all the
plants in place you know they've even
like cut off the tops of some of the
hills and you know that's all changed so
natural consciousness can go through
this process and realize this a lot of
times so I can realize the truth of
sensor then something happens and Hegel
describes this in a way that's a little
bit puzzling he says it's always
reaching this result learning from
experience what's true nut but equally
it's always forgetting and starting the
movement all over again now he doesn't
explain why we go through this
forgetting it could be in part because
we haven't sort of dialectically
consolidated it for our self through
some sort of intellectual practice could
be that you know we're just sort of torn
away by the cares of a busy life and we
you know come back to these these cycles
over and over again but natural
consciousness so long as it doesn't
learn its lesson and retain that
knowledge isn't going to advance but it
does go through this cycle over and over
so Hill says therefore astonishing when
in the face of this experience that that
ordinary people can have the
Philosopher's assert as universal
experience that an asserted as a
philosophical proposition even as the
outcome of skepticism
we've got Hume and Kant and people like
this in mine that the reality or being
of external things taken as this is or
since objects has absolute truth for
consciousness you know you can say to
yourself I don't know whether that
corresponds to something out there real
in the world but I know that I'm having
this experience and I can be like
totally sure that I'm having this
experience and what it is and if you're
an empiricist then you use those as kind
of building blocks if you if you read
you know authors like say lock or hume
you see that they think that we have
these perceptions and these perceptions
give us these basic ideas and we build
up our experience out of them sort of
like a bunch of Legos or you know with
Locke it's a little bit more like
chemical composition you put together
you know this element and that element
and you get something else that's
interesting instead so people say no
that's not actually how things work the
reality or being of external things
taken as this is her sense of objects
does not have absolute truth for
consciousness he says to make such an
assertion is not to know what one is
saying or to be unaware that one is
saying the opposite of what one wants to
say the truth for consciousness of this
of sense is supposed to be universal
experience so my sense experience even
though it's my sense experience should
be universal experience which means that
whatever it is that I'm sensing say you
know we
and we talked about a green ball with a
red spot I love this role you know I'm
imagining that and I'm also saying that
I perceive it you should be able to do
exactly the same thing you should be
able to replicate the thought experiment
take thing no it doesn't actually work
like that to begin with things are how a
lot more complicated in perception than
that and also they're you know not
absolute they're absolute status if
they're gonna have any is going to come
in a composite hole with other things
that arrange them that put them in order
you might say so he says every
consciousness itself supersedes this
kind of truth we've just seen that
here's a tree or now as noon and it
proclaims the opposite here's not a tree
but a house and what consciousness is
going to learn from experience is only
what we've seen that this is a universal
or the very opposite of with an
assertion affirm to be the universal
experience so it's not the sensations or
the sense data or the sense perceptions
that are really the truth and the you
know the thing that matters in sense
certainty it's the universals that we
use to make sense of them and these
aren't just you know sort of categories
of the understanding that give us pure
concepts then you know we then apply to
experience now these are actually
linguistic these are actually to a
certain degree as we're gonna see later
on social there are a lot closer to us
you know when I
this is gonna be a little digression
what I read cut I enjoyed reading Kant
but I feel like that I that he's
describing who's doing all that you know
projecting categories and conceptions
and you know having Sense experience so
different from me so distant from what
yes that I actually experience that it's
kind of hard to see it as anything other
than
kind of playing around with with stuff
perhaps s that's just me with Hegel I
can actually say yeah I can I can relate
to this a lot better to go on to the
third thing he talks about these
mysteries as being a symbol now I don't
want people you know to start saying oh
yeah I knew it Hegel's a new age for
anything like that he doesn't have
anything like that in mind he says you
know with this appeal to universal
experience we may be permitted to
anticipate how the case stands in the
practical sphere so what is it in our
actions that reveals to us how we
actually ought to treat things of
sense-perception
he says we can tell those who assert the
truth and certainty of the reality of
sense objects that they should go back
to the most elementary school of wisdom
the ancient Elliot Ellen moon that was
seeing in mysteries of Ceres and Bacchus
I always have trouble pronouncing that
word which is strange because I usually
don't have any trouble with the other
and I know you know things in Greek and
that they have to learn the secret
meaning of the eating of bread and
drinking of wine now is he saying that
you need to go to Mass where they eat
bread and drink wine is he saying that
you need to go find yourself someplace
in ancient Greece or in modern-day
Greece where they're gonna practice
these you know find some the O'Hagan's
to do this or maybe do it yourself in
your basement or your study no he's not
saying that he's saying just think about
what what's actually met by these these
mysteries when we're talking about a
mystery we're talking about something
that's not actually supposed to remain
mysterious for those who are initiated
in the mysteries there's supposed to be
some sort of meaning some sort of deeper
understanding that's being afforded
which can be articulated and the deeper
meaning is that when it comes to
sensible things we should doubt their
being now it's interesting because a
word here for doubt this is something a
lot of commentators
picked up on is why phone yeah you know
in German advise tubes by phone you no
doubt there's a connection between
between splitting and you know having
two possibilities it really does fit
here though because what happens when
we're going through this whole dialectic
we we see that things actually split
into two that there's a relation between
the self and the other the things are
mediated through each other so to doubt
is to is to say maybe there's more going
on here to doubt the beating of them
doesn't mean I sort of I don't think
they exist at all but it's rather to say
I doubt whether they have genuine being
I doubt whether the bread really is what
it purports to be I doubt that the wine
is really absolute being so in a certain
sense it's the opposite hails talking
about here of what say you know
Christians who believe in you know the
Eucharist or the mystery however you
want to you know translate the term
where the bread and the wine somehow you
know become God
Hegel's not saying that he's saying the
opposite of it he's saying the bread and
wine are really empty they become mere
symbols and what do we do now the word
the reason I put - here is because Hegel
is talking about Nick T cut he's not
saying Nick's it's it's a nothing Ness a
condition of beating nothing and we
contribute that to these sensible things
he says the one who is initiated in
these mysteries not only comes to doubt
the being of them but to despair of it
what does it mean to despair of it in
party brings about the nothingness of
such things himself in his dealings with
them we're gonna see what that means in
just a second but the human being is
contributing a nothingness to those
beings
he says in part he sees them reduce
themselves to nothingness he sees them
for what they truly are he sees the
truth of their limited being that they
really devolve into nothingness if not
being nothing being pretty close to it
yeah here it gets kind of funny you
notice I just put here eat him up
why did I put that
because Hegel says that's what the
animals are smart enough to do you know
put bread in front of a dog the dog is
not going to say what should I make of
this bread the dog just gobbles it up
why because the bread doesn't really
matter in certain respects the bread
matters insofar as it can give the dog
calories and the dog likes the taste and
all that but it doesn't have any being
that has to be respected you're not
gonna take you're gonna find a dog at
least you know taking a piece of bread
and putting it up on some sort of you
know altar and saying oh we must
preserve this forever and ever and ever
no the don't just eats it up and most
human beings will eat up bread you know
so he says even the animals are not shut
out from his wisdom they show themselves
to be most profoundly initiated into it
does that mean that the dogs are part of
the alone lesson in mystery is not with
it means that they're doing this by
their nature they don't see an eye on
the idly in front of sensuous things as
if they possess intrinsic being as if
they actually had value or per Durance
in and of themselves but despairing of
their reality and completely assured of
their nothingness they fall to and eat
them up they just gobbled them down and
he says all nature like the animal
celebrates these open mysteries which
teach us about sensuous things he's not
saying the sensuous things don't matter
that they don't have any value but the
value that they have is rather limited
so you know what does that mean as far
as our quest for absolute knowledge
we're not going to find it here
but just as their previous remarks would
suggest those who put forward such an
assertion also themselves say the direct
opposite of what they mean a phenomenon
which is perhaps best calculated to
induce them to reflect on the nature of
sense certainty they speak of the
existence of external objects which can
be more precisely defined as actual
absolutely singular wholly personal
individual things each of them
absolutely unlike anything else this
existence they say has absolute
certainty and truth they mean this bit
of paper on which I am writing or rather
have written this but what they mean is
not what they say if they actually
wanted to say this bit of paper which
they mean if they wanted to say it then
this is impossible because the sensuous
this that is meant cannot be reached by
language which belongs to consciousness
that is to that which is inherently
universal in the actual attempt to say
it it would therefore crumble away those
who started to describe it would not be
able to complete the description what
would be compelled to leave it to others
who would then Estelle's finally have to
admit to speaking about something which
is not they certainly mean then this bit
of paper here which is quite different
from the bit mentioned above but they
say actual things external or sensuous
objects absolutely singular entities and
so on that is they say of them only what
is universal consequently what is called
the unutterable as nothing else than the
untrue the irrational what is merely
meant but what is not actually expressed
if nothing more instead of something
then that is an actual thing an external
object its description is only the most
abstract of generalities and in fact
expresses its sameness with everything
rather than its distinctiveness when I
say a single thing I am really saying
what it is from a wholly universal point
of view for
is a single thing and likewise this
thing is anything you like if we
describe it more exactly as this bit of
paper then each and every bit of paper
is this bit of paper and I have only
uttered the universal all the time but
if I want to help out a language which
hand of the divine a nature of directly
reversing the meaning of what is said of
making it into something else
and thus not letting want as men to get
into words at all by pointing out this
bit of paper experience teaches me what
the truth is that certainty in fact is I
pointed out as a here which is a here of
other years or it isn't its own self a
simple togetherness of many years that
is is it is a universal I take it up
then as it is in truth and instead of
knowing something immediate I take the
truth of it or perceive it
we've finally reached the end of the
section on sense certainty our very
first section in the phenomenology
proper and what we're going to do now is
make the transition into the next
section which is on perception still in
in the frame of consciousness and Hegel
is going to bring about a transition to
that at the very end of this section
we'll talk about the play on words
that's involved there in just a moment
but he's going back to this notion of
sense certainty and the kind of ideas
underlying it that are appealed to by
empiricist philosophy and I was not
really wanted it had purported to be and
I said having shown us a different kind
of truth something else that's going on
within it so he says that some people
speak of the existence of external
objects and they define these you know
more precisely as actual absolutely
singular wholly personal individual
beings and they say each of them is
absolutely unlike anything else so we
have these just raw basic particulars
that then we take in through our sense
perception and we begin to you know
associate them through ideas and you
know we made them you have stuff like
this going on over here with the
universals that we form you know through
language through consciousness but those
are usually just sort of an assemblage
like a composite picture of these things
or we take one of them to stand in for
for the other and that's really you know
the empiricist theory of perception and
abstraction going on there now Hegel
says that really doesn't work and people
who talk like that aren't completely
thinking through what it is that they're
saying why he says they think that that
that existence has absolute certainty
and truth but it doesn't why not well
let's take an example this paper and now
we can do a couple different playing
around with this
Hegel is actually talking about the
piece of paper that he's writing in his
manuscript so we don't have that in
front of us as a prop that we could use
but let's just pretend that this book
this book right here is this paper this
this sheet of paper that he's writing on
and we've got sort of an invisible
Haegele of that as long as while we're
reading he's writing right so if they
mean this been a bit of paper on which
I'm writing would rather have written
this but what they mean is not what they
say if they actually want to say this
bit of paper which they mean if they
wanted to say it to express it that's
impossible
why is that the case well because you
know singularity or you know sort of
personal totally you know surd identity
is not susceptible to being framed
within language we've already talked
about this before the eye
I can't reserve the eye just for me or
it turns into a crazy nonsense word that
doesn't mean anything
boys suppose a proper name but even
proper names are in a certain way
Universal insofar as the proper names so
there's kind of a dividing line between
what would be over on this side and be
totally Universal totally singular
totally actual and then the abstractions
in our head the language that we speak
so if we're gonna talk about this piece
of paper I'm talking about this little
piece of paper here but that piece of
paper quickly becomes just a bunch of
linguistic signs or a bunch of
conceptions that we have so he says this
sensuous this that as men cannot be
reached by language that belongs to
consciousness to what is inherently
universal so in in calling it paper
I'm already associating it with all the
conceptions that I have of paper with a
universal of paper with the word paper
with the consciousness that I have the
thought of paper and I lose sight of
this actual thing in front of me
the empiricists might say so what so he
says those who started to describe it
would not be able to complete the
description as soon as you try to
describe something to say well what it
what is it about that piece of paper
imagine if Hegel we're doing that well
that manuscript paper Oh manuscript
paper Universal expressed in language
that white piece of paper
why universal expressive language we can
go down and talk about as many qualities
or as many predicates as we want they're
always going to be expressed in language
they're always going to be universals
and so they're always not getting there
- the thing itself that's supposed to be
more real supposed to have the absolute
certainty and truth so it says they
certainly mean this bit of paper which
is different from the other good above
but they say things like actual things
or sensuous objects or absolutely
singular entities and when they do that
generates interesting words like this
our words aren't they they're universals
every single thing is a single thing
right
they all have singularity in common we
can say they in the unity at least the
medievals would say well they have unity
in common you know but if we want to try
to emphasize how different they are from
everything else even the property of
being completely different than
everything else is a property and falls
on the side of this which means that all
of this stuff is actually subsumed in
here this is actually abstract it's not
concrete to talk about some purely you
know beyond any sort of language
experience you do that in language so
Hegel is pointing out a problematic
inherent in any of this the sort of
thing we're already in the realm of
consciousness we're already in the realm
of language and the universal so he goes
on and he says what is called the
unutterable is
nothing else than the untrue the
irrational what is merely meant but not
mere not expressed so if you can't
express if you're going to talk about
the unimaginable or the unutterable or
the impossible to include within the
realm of our consciousness you got one
of two choices it's a dilemma either
you're actually talking about something
that you can frame within language and
that it does have some sort of you know
uh durability or conceived ability or
imagined ability because you're already
doing that or it's like totally beyond
the pale and you're just standing there
in a spouting nonsense so this is a real
dividing point here he says if nothing
more is said of something than that it
is an actual thing or external object
that's the most abstract of generalities
you're not actually saying anything
there you may intend to be saying
something you may feel like you're
saying something but it doesn't have any
real cognitive content what actually
does have cognitive content well when
you look at this paper and you the eye
is perceiving it and you the eye is
pointing it out and you the eye is
talking about it you are treating that
paper as a this or as a year and what
have we observed about this and here
they're actually universals so what this
means according to Hegel is that when
you're grasping some sensuous particular
as what it is when you're grasping the
truth you are grasping the truth of that
sensuous particular you're doing it
through the universal interestingly
enough what does it mean to grasp the
truth of the universal particular in the
universal in German there's a play on
words and that's what he's going to
conclude
anyone really does like to to play with
language whenever you can people you
know often is a total digression but
people often criticize you know
Heidegger or Derrida Oerlikon for you
know making all sorts of puns and plays
on words this guy does it all the time
it's just oftentimes people don't catch
it quite as much any true VAR height is
true so far name'll is perception bar
Nathan that's the verb for to take or to
grasp so if you're grasping the bar
height the truth of the sensuous
particular through the universal you are
engaging in varna Mon you are you know
or you know the verb would be bar name
and write the name of the bar yeah so
what this means is that you're actually
perceiving the sensuous particular and
what it means to perceive is to have the
universal under which we can actually
bring it now that doesn't mean that it's
a pure quality of just sort of naming or
abstraction or anything else we're gonna
see that as we move into this next
section keep in mind that all these
dialectical advances that we've had so
you seeing the here for example as being
a multiplicity of years as being a
universal in itself as having mediation
as having negativity we want to hold on
to all of that as we go into that